Alright. So, let's
get started.
So, greetings, everybody.
My my name is Mike Atkin.
I am the director
of the Enterprise
Knowledge Graph Foundation.
I also work at
a knowledge graph
consulting firm
called Agnos dot
AI in London.
So, on Monday,
we organized two
sessions focusing
on the business
and implementation
issues kind of
affecting knowledge
graph adoption. Right?
We had various viewpoints.
We have participants from
Accenture and from
AstraZeneca,
UBS, Capital One,
Johnson and Johnson,
a fashion knowledge
graph, called,
Zalando, and a fintech,
in financial services
called Noonan.
And we organized
a session around,
hypothesis. So let me give you
that hypothesis,
and we'll start with that,
and then we'll get into it.
So, from my perspective, the,
knowledge graph equation kinda
starts with
the recognition that
we have, data incongruence.
It's a liability.
It's a real problem.
And most people
are recognizing
that problem as
being something
to address.
We know the problem
is solvable.
We also know that it's easier
to solve this
problem semantically
than it is using conventional
technology. Right?
We know that making the leap
from columns to concepts
is achievable,
but it's certainly
not automatic.
And we also know
that leadership
is required because there's
organizational
inertia that you
have to overcome for any new
thing that's introduced into
an organization.
So the community of knowledge
graph practitioners,
we are completely
enamored with,
of course, with the potential
of knowledge graph because of
all the capability provided by
semantic standards. Right?
We know that subject
matter expertise,
knowledge can be modeled.
It can be modeled precisely.
We can express that
in a standard way.
We can achieve
unambiguous shared
meaning, which is
always our goal.
Right? The fact that we can
solve it is
a compelling story.
I'm gonna say it's
an overwhelmingly
compelling story.
So our goal was
to look at what's
required to expedite adoption
and where are we
in that curve,
and what do we need to do to
continue this movement along
that pathway. So this is gonna
be a summary of
what we learned,
maybe a bit of extra analysis
thrown in if we
feel compelled.
And to help me do
that are two people,
so Teresa Tong from
Accenture and,
Lauren Dakiya from,
Johnson and Johnson.
I'll let you guys
introduce yourself,
and then we'll get into it.
So, Teresa, let's
start with you.
Hi. This is Teresa Tongue.
I'm a, managing
director at Accenture.
I'm the chief
technologist within
our cloud first business.
And I've been working with
enterprise knowledge
graphs over
the past eight years and most
recently have been doing a lot
more work, bringing it out of
pilot into something
that's more
organized across
our business.
Terrific. Morant?
And, Noel Kaye.
I'm I'm, part of
a small team in,
Johnson Johnson around the,
enterprise IT, working
on, everything,
emerging technologies.
And I've been working with,
Semantic Technologies
for the past
twelve years, mostly.
First as a a a side
project and then,
more recently, as a more,
significant part
of, of my work.
And, we're very
early on that,
on the other journey
around the.
Alright. So, Teresa,
you've agreed to be
my first victim.
We're gonna talk
about the business
side of the equation.
And there were there
were, I think,
like, four big topics that
occurred in the conversation.
The first one was
about cognition.
Right? It was about,
do stakeholders
really get the joke?
Do they understand the data
incongruence
problem at a level
that's gonna lead us into this
type of solution?
What what do you think we what
do we learn from
that conversation?
Yeah. I mean, I
think that that
that's one of
the biggest changes.
Right? So I think the the data
incongruence problem,
it's always been a problem,
and people have
thought of it as,
you know, it it's
it's a manual step.
We'd have to deal with it.
It's it's par for course.
And I think the change is that
the business stakeholders are
not only recognizing
the challenge
as an important
thing to solve,
but as an opportunity.
The need to be data centric is
going to be how they are going
to compete. Right?
So our oil and gas clients,
the way they pull
oil from the ground
and refine it and deliver it,
actually compete upon
how they do that.
How they're going
to compete is
the enterprise knowledge graph
is really what's
needed to really
bring the smarts,
bring the agility.
And and these business people
are very savvy. Right?
They they experience
the impact
of enterprise knowledge graphs
in their consumer
lives. Right?
So when they do
web searches on,
online, when
they're interfacing
with the chatbot,
when they're online shopping,
so they they do
wonder why can't
we bring some of
those experiences
to how their business. Right?
It it's it's Yeah.
I was really I
was really taken
I was really taken
by that concept
of data centricity.
You know, that was like a I
think throughout all
the conversations,
we kinda got the sense that
people are putting data first
as opposed to
technology first.
That's a pretty huge shift,
don't you think? It is.
And I think it's part of it is
because of that
intelligence, right?
That, that data
driven business,
to power things like AI.
And even with the pandemic,
I would say that it's not so
much just AI. It's, it's,
it's knowing data real time,
seeing a very,
seeing the view you wanna see
about the business.
When something changed,
it's not about
projecting a year
from now. That's
important too.
But what's happening now,
and what can I do about it
different part?
seeing this from
the same single
source of truth,
but the the view
that you wanna
see is that data centricity.
You know, so we can,
maybe check a box
and say that,
generally, the,
stakeholders at the,
you know, in
charge of business
and organization do understand
this problem and are kind of
viewing it in the right way.
So that that's
that's, I think,
progress for our industry.
The second topic, kind
of in my opinion,
was really about
maturity. Right?
And and and we we
kind of framed
it saying, let's look at three
levels of maturity.
We have a maturity model we've
been working on and
kinda just kind of,
frame that real quickly.
We have level one,
which is experiments,
you know, POCs.
You're building
your own specialist
team and you're,
doing a project.
Right? Somebody is willing to
pay for it, but you're
doing a project.
Level two, that's
where it starts
to become extensible.
We've got shared ontologies.
We're beginning
to build a center
of excellence. And
then level three,
when we extend it out
to the enterprise
kind of as a, a platform for
the organization.
So, I was,
pretty impressed
that the industry
has made a leap
from experiments
almost to
the enterprise level.
What what did you
hear in this,
Teresa? Yeah. I I
heard very similar.
I I'm sure part of the reason
we were panelists was because
we we had experience
in the topic.
But all the panelists
were, you know,
moving out of level one.
So within their
organizations,
they had pockets where people
had already experimented with
knowledge graphs
and have proven
the value for knowledge graph
powered applications.
So this might be within a line
of business or
within a particular
use case.
And people were
looking towards,
again, returning to
that level too.
Right? So how do
you connect and
across the different parts of
the business that figuring out
how do I make this applicable
for my business?
How do I make this
enterprise ready?
And I think one of the key
takeaways from the panel was
that you really need
to band together.
Because when you're
in level one,
you can have a strong
business champion.
That is that's what
you need. Right?
You need a business
champion with that,
the funding, with the team,
with the use case,
and the the,
the channel to
make a difference
for your business.
But then as you move to level
two so that this
doesn't become
a POC and sells there,
but actually
changes the way you
manage your data,
now that banding together is
actually not that
lone champion,
but a federated
coalition across
the business that
is gonna agree
upon certain things.
And, and some of the things
we're doing is agreeing upon
even the graph
database or even
the query interface,
Gremlin, GraphQL.
Right? So how do we
work with cloud?
Do we use the cloud
cloud graph,
offerings, or do
we do something,
that is more,
migratable? Right?
So all these questions as you
band together is
gonna help you,
have, you know,
power numbers.
Very significant. Right?
Because, previously,
we if in terms of
sustainability,
if you have to
rely on a single
champion and that
champion moves on,
your whole project's at risk.
And I think it it
kinda got a sense
that, as you just said,
we kinda are moving
beyond the need
for a sole, skirt
to hide behind,
if you will. Yes.
I was also, pretty,
impressed that I
guess the general
sense was we've moved out of
the academic realm
and now into
the applications realm,
and that's also a big
leap, I think,
that that has occurred.
I think the third topic that I
heard was really
about the driving
use cases.
And, you know,
maybe I can frame
that a little
bit for you because
I hear two sides.
There's a control
type of activity,
resiliency and organizational
management, and
there's a business
function, you know,
applications that are designed
for revenue and
customer service.
What do you see right now as
the driving applications for
knowledge graph?
So it seemed across the board
that we saw data
as the driving
application. So data in a lot
of ways that that serves some
of that function. Right?
So data and then
inventory of data,
like a new sort of,
data management.
So going beyond your
data glossaries,
to something that
actually manages
the information and,
makes that data reusable.
It's the data integration and
using a knowledge
graph to make
it easy to both,
stitch together
data from others
and to reuse that. Right?
So you're not,
doing it time and
time again, but
you could actually
add the right
quality rules and
and really,
manage and and
connect the lineage
of of your data
supply chains.
And then your flexible query,
and this this does
lead into the app,
but it wasn't
driven necessarily
by the app itself.
It's not saying
we're gonna have
a chatbot, and that's
the killer app,
or customer service,
recommendations as
a cut killer app,
the the flexible query that
actually is gonna
change a business
process. Right?
So if you imagine,
the way that you might do,
even manufacturing
today, right?
Like you would want to be able
to see right away,
all the data that you have as
to what's
manufacturable within
your supply chain.
And a lot of what is needed is
dependent on context.
So to even to be able to have
a flexible query
that a a business
analyst or user could
actually find,
that's gonna power a a new set
of applications that's beyond
a killer app. Right?
It's actually
the value of itself.
You You know, I
think there was
a there was
a a seemingly a little
bit of a dark cloud that hung
over the conversation
because,
it does require an investment
to become operational,
and you do have to
have some patience.
But once you are
operational at
that foundation level,
I guess the message was it's
easier to continue to add,
business driving use cases.
And, you know, what maybe you
call that a semantic hump.
It's kind of what
I what I glean
from the conversation.
Is that kind of
reality the way
you see it? I think
it's definitely
reality, and I
think that's why
you you have
the maturity levels
the way that you
you had specified.
So within your level ones,
you do have people who do take
a leap of faith. Right?
There's there is somebody who
has to buy into modeling data
in its own right,
before you go to
the application.
And and that's where you're
going to actually
build a foundation.
And I think the sell as far as
what we started with
the, you know,
realization from the business
is that the sell is actually
easy after that. Right?
So I think people have,
been burned a bit from maybe
master data management and
traditional data management.
People have, you know,
reimplemented the same
data pipelines.
How many of you
have put in maps
or put in social media or put
in the same sort
of data sources?
And you do this time and time
and time again,
and very little
of it is reused.
And, if we talk about
things that are,
you know, even
a data glossary,
we have data stewards
like we do this,
right? But none
of that is easily
reused. A lot of
that is manual,
right? It's very hard when
something changes.
It's a whole another
manual process.
And so the sell
as to, you know,
get the buy in to say, look,
I I have this already.
I've modeled the concepts.
Now this data is
understandable.
People can reuse
it for different
reasons. And if I wanna change
it and I wanna
now think about,
I think they want
an example of
sustainability. People wanna
think about
sustainability now.
That wasn't
something they were
looking at. It
was very easy to
add that label and
to propagate it.
Right? You didn't have to have
a whole other,
big data project.
So forgive me for my German
shepherd alarm
clock going off,
but the mail was
just delivered.
I think you, you
touched on what
I also heard is
probably the key
value proposition,
which is that
reusability of data.
And if there was one theme at
the end of this section of our
conversation, it
was that those
fundamental, knowledge graph
capabilities,
you know, reuse,
meaning resolution,
and all the rest
that really do
win the day. That's kind of
where I I walked away feeling
pretty good about
the direction
of that conversation.
For sure.
I mean, the value I think
everybody agreed
was upon the self
describing nature
that the knowledge
graph gives to
our data. Right?
So now I can because we model
the data as it's collected,
if I wanna re examine
it for reuse,
if I even wanna
track back things
around the lineage
and and where
it's coming from,
the richness of that metadata
that allows the humans now,
to figure out, does
this concept apply?
Right? So if I'm
getting a reading
from a temperature pump and I
know how it's measured,
there's many ways
that I can use that.
Right? But if we actually cast
it right away into
an application,
we lose all that, that,
that value there.
And so the ability
to actually,
capture this in
a way that then
needs to become
democratized for
your normal, you know,
non data scientist,
non data geek to look at,
your business user,
your insurance agent,
your doctor.
Right? I think
that's where I'm
really excited
about this because
they do think in
those sorts of
conceptual terms,
not, you know,
the traditional
data terms that
we look at right
now. Alright.
So let's shift
the conversation
from the business narrative,
which I think was
a good news story,
you know, which is
it's emerging,
to, implementation reality.
And, Lauren, you've agreed to
be our victim for kind
of the implementation
. I'm gonna bridge
the gap between
this business
narrative and and
implementation.
And let me kinda
pick up from what was maybe
underscoring some
of what Teresa
said just now, which is,
don't focus on
the technology.
Right? This is the you know,
you you don't have
to sell people
on knowledge graph.
We're selling people
on business value.
Right? So how do we make that
that relationship
with the business
user one that is the driving
activity in our
conversations?
One way of doing that is about
by making it simple,
hiding the semantics,
hiding the complexity,
and providing simple
lenses into what,
what you've built,
in in your in your
knowledge graph.
So hiding the semantics,
automating everything,
you can automate so that you
don't you don't
have to involve
people in manual tasks,
that that they're not prepare
prepare for.
Try to reduce as
much as possible
the need for ontologist.
And you still
need ontologist.
You still need
a a semantic architect,
but, have them,
more on the the the long term
vision and the the,
in in a role to
avoid pitfalls,
to avoid, issues, and,
lead the day to day,
operations to you know,
in in using tools
that are that
are simple to use.
That's a good idea.
That's a problem
for us. Right?
Because, a lot
of the people in
the community like
to talk about
the technology. Right?
We are we are focused on,
breaking new ground,
and we wanna talk
about triples
and semantic, you know,
engineering and the like.
And, really, I
think the message
was talk about
data visualization
and navigation and
query. Right?
So you probably
are experiencing
that yourself in
the rollout of,
knowledge graph in
Johnson and Johnson.
Yeah. We were talking
earlier about,
stories, telling
better stories to,
to share the value of,
of of doing it this way.
And one thing that
I've run into
is how do you talk about,
knowledge graphs and semantic
technologies without
using the word
graph and the word semantics?
Forget about the technology or
hide the technology
and focus on what,
what you are trying
to accomplish,
what will be
the the real benefits
of doing it, in in
in a different way.
But if people knew
how wonderful
and important and
magnificent this was,
then they would automatically
be the same way
as we are talking
about the data concepts
and semantics.
No. No. Just Those who get it
those who get it
and and and are
willing to get into
the technology
often become very
enthusiastic about it.
Yeah. So I think
tell a good story,
and a good story
does not start
with the the word ontology or
the concept of
semantic capability.
Right? So the second topic I'm
gonna say was kind
of built on that,
almost a bat a battle
for mind share.
Right? This is, you know,
how do we make knowledge graph
work with existing
infrastructures.
Right? Because
there are existing
infrastructures. They're not
gonna rip and replace them,
and we have to blend this.
So what do we learn
about the ability
to blend semantic
technology with,
legacy environments?
We're here to you,
you have to make it fit with,
with existing
environment, and,
that's one of
the the beauty of,
of, of the the approach
is that
it doesn't have
to disturb what's
already there. You
can, automatically,
I mean, you can you can set up
automatic processes
that extract
the data, that
promotes data, that,
organize the data
into into a graph
without, touching
what's what's
already in place.
And the That
abstraction layer.
I think you you
you you described
it as an abstraction
layer, which is,
I think, was maybe
one of the key
themes that I heard
in the conversation.
Yeah. In that sense,
the the knowledge
was are, a map,
linking together
the the the physical
infrastructure,
the physical data data storage
or the data documentation.
And, one thing I've
seen is a it's
a I've seen some
some investment
fatigue or rec
reluctance to to
invest into yet
another platform
because a few years ago,
we we had to invest
to do big data,
and then we had
to invest to do,
data lakes, or or
data warehouses
along the way. And now you're
telling me that there wasn't
enough you needed to do,
that stuff on top of it.
And, so that that's, again,
part of telling the story and
showing that, yes,
you need you need that to to
make it fit and make it work
better at a larger scale,
but it doesn't
detract from what
you've done before.
It just builds on top of it.
But this is
the difference between
data processing technology
orientation and data meaning
content orientation.
We're now talking
about the content
side of the equation. Right?
Your poor, humble
data is finally
getting its due.
Right? You know?
And it would have been a lot
harder to do without
the data lakes,
without the data
data warehouses
and so on.
I think it was
you who described
it that there is
a challenge, however,
that you have to
overcome the relational
masses. I think
that was a a quote
that I heard used
frequently. Right?
The skill sets of how to get
people to move
into the semantic
world are not really easy to
come by and are not present at
the moment in
organizations. Yes.
And that's it's not
only a skill set,
but it's also a a mindset.
You have to think you have to
to sell ideas such as,
there is no single
version of truth.
You you you can
build an environment
that shows
multiple perspectives
depending on on
your, your needs.
And and all those source of
truth can coexist
and be linked
together and and
provide answers.
The other thing the other big
idea that that helps,
selling this is to to really
build things incrementally.
And in a way,
redefine the idea
of a quick win
or low hanging
hanging fruits.
It's not about fixing creating
a project that that
answers a problem
immediately or in
the short short term,
but it's about answering real
questions in a way that builds
incrementally on
top of a a common
structure. So
the the key aspect
of this is to to
build to build
that common data
data structure
that will evolve and Yeah.
I I think evolve into
a knowledge graph.
That that that led into this
notion of
the importance of the,
what they call it,
the knowledge
engineer. Right?
The the the person who helps
bridge the gap.
There there while
we are trying to,
deliver for business,
there is a big,
huge requirement
for that semantic
engineer, knowledge engineer,
to help us get in
that get that way.
I think that was clear theme
that I heard throughout this
conversation. And
you need a mix
of perspectives.
You need, to involve,
the data engineer,
the ontologist, but also,
the business people,
the data science,
machine learning,
and all of that
having get and,
again, working
on incremental,
delivery of solution is a good
way to to get
everybody involved
and and develop that shared
understanding. Yeah.
It's a it's
a true collaboration
process. And I'm curious.
I I know we didn't really talk
about this, but
I'm I'm curious
about the process of getting
the full ecosystem
to buy in to
the changes that
are going on.
That's been probably part of
the organizational
journey that
we have to pay attention to,
how to make that transition
across multiple
departments. Yeah.
That's something
we we said a a
little earlier. No.
I was thinking
it's it's a it's
really a chicken and,
and egg problem because,
in order to show the value,
you need to to build it,
but you don't get
the resources
to build it unless
you show value.
So So the the the third topic
that we were talking about was
really about the whole data
pipeline itself. Right?
There's there's, you know,
managing meaning is different
than managing processing.
And there are some delusions
that exist in the organization
that we do have to
overcome. Right?
I think there were
some themes about,
you know,
shifting from structuring data
to semantic mapping of data,
and that was
a a big, concept.
Yeah. It is, like I said,
I just said, I I
thought you did
a bit of that,
just before. Yeah.
It's it's really
a a a shift in
mindset that you
you have to and,
fortunately, you can find some
people in in
your organizations
that are already primed to
thinking in terms of concepts
that have been exposed to this
kind of problem.
They can become
bigger advocate
if you if you
find them and and
involve them early
because this
solves their their
their problems.
So, like,
master master data
management people,
who have run into those,
those issues of
bottom up versus
top down approaches
of building
golden records and and and,
ideal models of of data.
This type of
technology can help
them go over that that,
hurdle that they that they are
getting into and and really
create something that will,
that is not just
an ideal exercise of,
conceptualizing a space,
but it's something
very practical
that answer questions.
So weaning ourself off that
concept of the single
version of truth,
very difficult because we've
kind of embedded that into our
mindset coming from core data
management. And
now we have kind
of a different objective,
but it's hard to make that
transition in people's
minds. It's hard.
But, again, storytelling
helps there.
You can you can get people to
to come to that understanding
with with very
simple stories.
Like, if you think
of describing
a house, in term
of real estate,
you're going to to use very
different
relationships and and
and vocabularies
than if you're
describing it, the same house
in term of, historical,
historical heritage
or in term of,
I don't know,
industrial zoning.
So having stories like that to
to to demonstrate that you you
need multiple perspective,
and it's still
the same house,
but you need to look at it in
through different
lens lenses.
And having
a a a knowledge graph
helps capture all
those lenses,
capture all those decisions
about the rules
around data into
a format that
will that you can
use to answer questions.
This is all about
context. Right?
And I think my I,
reflected after our
session, really,
there's only four
things we need
for all context. Right?
Identity, meaning,
time, and, source.
With that, you
can construct any
reality that exists,
and that's what is captured in
a knowledge graph.
So weeding ourselves
from these
old concepts are hard,
but the capabilities
of the graph
seem to we gotta
lead us in that
direction.
So the final topic on
this section was,
really about governance.
Governance.
Right? And I think there was I
guess I heard a big shift in
the way we think
about governance
from our core data management
experiences to our knowledge
graph world. What
did you hear?
Yeah. And, to me,
the the big
takeaway was that,
the knowledge graph is really
the the the embodiment
of all those,
governance decision that,
that you may building a master
data model and and
aligning data,
integrating data,
instead of having those,
those decision be dispersed
throughout the whole
pipeline,
you can physically represent
them inside of
a structure that,
at any given time
will tell you
how you're you're
looking at your data.
And when you add
on top of that,
data validation
approaches like,
like, Shackle, for example,
you can really compare,
what data systems
are providing
you and what you are expecting
and detect a much earlier
discontinue disc discrepancies
and and improve data
quality that way.
So before we open it up to see
if there's any questions from
the audience, let me just ask
both of you, you
had to summarize,
you know, kind of the takeaway
from these two
sessions we ran.
You know, what was
the big lesson?
What should people
walk away with?
What should they
remember about
this conversation?
So, Theresa, if you don't mind
on the fly, what's,
what are your thoughts about
the kind of the the big
message here?
I think now is the time for
enterprise knowledge graphs.
I think that was
the big takeaway.
It's it's the tech
has been around for,
I would say, over
a decade, right,
in a in a academic setting.
And if we, know,
the vendor maturity
and the tooling
being easier to use,
and it's not,
you know, just for
academics anymore,
it's more enterprise scale.
And then on the other side,
we have the business saying we
need this. This is how we're
going to compete.
We're gonna change
how we do it.
So I don't we need
to just bring
those things together.
I think that's our our,
opportunity here.
Warren, what's,
what's what's
the takeaway from
your orientation?
For me, it's,
you don't have to
wait for the ideal
technology to be out there.
Start building it.
You can start start now
incrementally
using, standards,
that decouple the data from
the technology,
and you can change
the technology
as long as it follows the same
standards, you
can remove remove
your current platform and and
and apply another one later.
It it should it
shouldn't matter.
So just, just start
start doing it now.
Yeah. Alright. So let's see if
there's any questions for,
us from the audience.
If there are other
questions you
wanna ask, these folks,
please just type them in.
I see one kind of looking at
this idea of the difference
between multiple truths and
multiple perspectives,
and I think that's
a real key concept.
So, Teresa, you know,
how do you see the distinction
between those two things?
Well, I mean, I
think the concepts,
like, I used an example
in the chat is,
like, there's Teresa. Right?
Let's say what what's what's
Teresa's temperature
right now?
And and I think there's both
multiple truths
and perspectives.
I usually answer
on the multiple
perspective side
to say there's
there's one truth and it it's
actually what you see,
like a different view
for the different
purpose. But I could see that
if we're actually
gonna have data,
data is measured, right,
or it's data is inputted.
So you could imagine
that one one,
thermometer reads
one thing and
the other thermometer reads
another thing. There there's
actually a truth of of what my
temperature really is,
but there's these two sources
that gives you
a version and a casting
of that first.
So one is the the
source of data and
and the measure
that's taken,
and the second is
the perspective
as it's applied.
So so maybe that's
too academic.
I I do see the chat
about, you know,
revenue and things.
But with this information,
now you can make the decision
for how you even,
report up to
regulatory. Right?
So we wanna make
the same level
of decisions to say,
if we're gonna use
a thermometer,
there's the one
that I buy from,
the drugstore.
And then the one
that's gone through,
you know,
the medical grade
device from the FDA.
And so if I'm making it,
a medical decision
about Teresa,
I better make sure it's using
the thermometer that's been,
medical grade, from the FDA,
not the one she bought from
the drugstore.
So the the definitions about
the source of
the data will give
you a way to
actually make sure
that your perspective and how
you're gonna use it
is is the right one.
So it sounds like it's kind of
putting the user
back in control.
Right? So you you
wanna be able
to access the data that is
relevant for your
application.
Is that similar, Lauren,
to what you're you're you're
thinking about? Yeah.
Not only that, but,
it captures
the the the the full
picture. Ideally,
it should capture
the full picture
of all those, assumptions,
all those decision
that you've made,
to to to decide
what is the the
the right perspective or what
is the right temperature.
So, it's done in
a way that, two,
programs can use to,
not only give you a result,
but also explain why.
They can give you
that reasoning of,
I gave you this temperature
because it came
from this source
that was preferred because of
that reason. And and
you the knowledge
graph should be able to derive
that and and provide
that answer.
And if you if you
wanted to ask
the knowledge
graph everything,
you would have also
the possibility
to view
a different perspective
and and make your own
choice. Alright.
So let's close it all.
I just have one question here
about user interfaces, right,
which I think is
really a question
about what's
the state of people
being able to
extract knowledge
from the graph,
and has it kept up
with the underlying
technologies that we're doing
to develop the graph?
So, Lauren, what what what's
your thought? Where where are
we on user interfaces?
Where is that headed?
And Theresa will do
the same for you.
So let's start
with you, Harr.
The user interface
is one thing
we discussed in in
in the the other
panel is you really
need to make
it beautiful, appealing,
easy to use,
and, engaging. And,
once one thing I
I I I've seen,
a lot of time, especially,
by necessity,
though, the way
things are done
through more the the academic
world is that
the user interfaces,
can be can be challenging,
when you look at,
at this kind of technology.
So, fortunately,
those platforms that
are coming online,
are addressing that.
It's it's becoming easier to
work with with
the technologies.
But, that that
should really be
a big emphasis because
without that,
it's going to be
very difficult to,
ideally, you need
something like
an Excel of,
the equivalent not
not the equivalent
of what Excel was
to to to to to,
spreadsheets. We
need something
as easy to use for
for Use managing,
yeah, managing,
semantic data.
So, Teresa, the,
the state of the customer
experience,
where where are we headed?
It could certainly be better.
I I I see a lot
of demos that,
I really don't like where,
they wanna show me
there's a graph,
and then they say, look.
Everyone's seen
this demo, like,
where you could
explode the graph.
Right? You have
the little node
and you walk and
you explode it
and you explode it
and you're like,
look, now you can
see this this
this this thought,
light train of thought.
Nobody wants to do that.
I don't want to
do that. Right?
So I think what
we want to have
is things that,
interesting thing.
And here's why
it's interesting.
It actually shows
you the trajectory.
And this is where, again,
if we do go from the consumer
world and where we do use
knowledge graphs,
let's say Wikipedia.
Right? And and,
these are how people
want to see it.
There's a graph back there.
Nobody actually sees it,
but it's it's it's there.
And so I think it could show
more explainability.
And that's actually
what you do
get from the graph or lineage
and understanding
which sources
and which people,
even put things in.
And that's
the richness that we
should be seeing.
So I think this is
a a, you know,
great place for our vendors to
actually help, right,
to create these
tools that make
this more user friendly.
And, again, not
the data scientist,
not the data engineer, but,
your business user. Alright.
So we'll let that
be the last word.
I almost wanted to,
thank you both for stepping in
last minute to help
us summarize.
It was a terrific experience.
So, thank you all
very much, and,
we will call this
session closed.
Thank you. Thank you.